- Welcome back, everybody.
A few weeks ago we had some of the stars
of the Netflix series "Bridgerton" here.
It was very exciting.
They were so fun and we
had so much to talk about,
that we couldn't fit it all into one show.
So, it was so fascinating
that I didn't want
anybody to miss a moment.
So here is the rest of that conversation
in what we call, a Kelly Extra.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Watching those girls dancing - oh, my...
and it doesn't matter
how many takes you do,
(audience cheering)
they're so on it.
They are just brilliant.
So it's beautiful to just watch.
- I love the balls as well.
And I love, I mean, just
'cause I'm a musician,
I love how they take like modern music
and you know, have like
an orchestra playing-
- [Nicola] You've gotta get
one of your songs in season three.
- You can, but you're already,
I think it would be lowering the bar.
You've been doing
- [Nicola] Stop it!
- like Alanis Morissette.
- [Nicola] Do you know who you are?
- No, I just mean, no, I just mean-
- [Adjoa] No.
- [Kelly] I just had
Alanis Morissette on here.
Who just did "You Oughta Know",
which was one of the raddest
songs in the whole world
and you fit it into Bridgerton.
- [Charithra] But it works so well!
It's the perfect song for that scene!
- [Kelly] It really did.
It's like, I literally-
- [Adjoa] Kelly!
- Oh, go ahead. I'm sorry.
- No, I wanted to say,
can we have "Broken and Beautiful" please?
Because my 25 year old
daughter, Daisy, and I,
we lose our S H one T over that song.
We love that song.
- I actually look, I feel like I can brag
about that one 'cause
that's one I didn't write.
Pink wrote it and I'm a huge fan of Pink.
So Pink actually wrote that song
and I got to sing it for this movie.
So I just love, though, that you take,
I mean just the fact that
you took "You Oughta Know",
I think you did "Material Girl",
you did, you've done
all these like classic,
just rock and roll songs
that everybody loves.
- Yeah.
And then Nirvana, too.
- [Kelly] And then puts
a ball around it.
Like you're like, wait, what?
- But, you know, it's a bit
of a surprise for us, too, watching it
because the songs that
we actually dance to
on set and that we rehearse with
are entirely different songs.
- Wait, so what if you
look like you're off tempo?
Like from what's-
- [Charithra] They have to pick a song-
- That's intermittent.
- Yeah.
- Actually Luke and I
danced to a modern song.
What was it?
(humming "Attention" by Charlie Puth)
- [Charithra] "Attention"
- Yeah, that one.
That's what we danced to
- Ooh.
and then they replaced it with classical.
- That's a good song.
- And mine was Nirvana's
"Smells Like Teen Spirit".
My dance with Johnny in the
diamond ball was Nirvana.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Nicola] I just have to
say, because I'm noticing it
and obviously I've known
Charithra for months,
but you have the most perfect
hair I have ever seen.
She doesn't have a split
end. It's literally insane.
- I'm gonna be honest with you, Nicola,
- I've been staring at your hair-
- When I hugged her a minute ago,
I felt like I was hugging
someone from a hair commercial.
- [Nicola] No, it like,
it's genuinely insane.
- It's so shiny.
I'm like, do you put, is there a routine
or it's just like that?
- [Nicola] Someone needs to
give this girl a hair deal,
like immediately.
- I literally hugged
you when you walked in.
And I was like, "Oh."
I was like, "Is that what
it's supposed to feel like?"
- [Charithra] Guys, I
paid the price growing up.
So my mom, the one thing
she would never let me do
was touch my hair.
So I wasn't even allowed
to hair dry my hair.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
My hair was like, purple
- [Charithra] Oh, never.
- and like, blue and like, black.
- [Nicola] I had the streaks,
the streaky highlights.
- [Charithra] Oh my God, that's amazing.
- I had those hair straighteners
that used to like, you know, spark
and then there'd be smoke
and I would just be
picking split ends off.
- [Kelly] And I'm like older than y'all,
so I also had perms 'cause
I'm a kid of the eighties.
So like, totally looked
so cool with my perms,
which did so much damage.
Anyway, obviously I'm so
excited about season three.
Are you excited about season three?
- I'm so excited.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- You're excited from the fitting.
- From the fitting. Do you know what?
The fitting was, you know,
I've done my two years
in the yellow dresses.
I've put my time in.
'Cause I always get cast as the character
and on the description it's like,
she's very clever, but
nobody finds her attractive
and she wears the wig.
And I'm always like, okay,
it's fine, I'll do my time.
But then when I went for this fitting,
I was like, "Oh, it's so beautiful."
Like this stuff,
- [Kelly] Aww.
- I mean, oh my God.
(crowd cheering)
I was really emotional.
I didn't expect to be, I don't know.
I just, John Glaser is
designing season three.
He worked with Ellen
Mirojnick on season one,
designing costumes but, he's a genius.
He's a genius.
And like I said, Luke Newton,
people are gonna lose their
minds when they see him.
They've like really, like
the glow up is gonna be real.
- The glow up!
- It's exciting. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I loved your family's story
this whole time around, too.
It was very intense.
- [Nicola] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Featheringtons.
- I didn't like him
from the beginning, but
I was just like, yeah.
- I know, and you know
what? He's, Rupert Young,
who plays cousin Jack, is
the nicest man in the world.
- [Kelly] Well, he plays an ass very well.
- [Nicola] Yes, he does!
- [Charithra] He's very nice.
- But we kept trying to think
of reasons that he would stay.
We were like, but maybe he's not bad,
just 'cause we liked having
Rupert around so much.
But I think, unfortunately,
he's a bad guy.
- [Kelly] Bye. I was like,
he did a really good job.
- [Nicola] He was great. So great.
- I know y'all are so amazing,
actors, how y'all do that.
I'm just like, are they, is that in there,
or are they just that good?
- Also like, and Polly
Walker, who plays my mom
in the show is like,
she always plays these
formidable
- [Charithra] I love her.
- women on TV, like really sassy.
Then in person, she's the warmest,
- [Charithra] Sweetest
- [Nicola] nicest, but
it's the nicest people
play the best baddies.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Nicola] Yeah. Always.
- It's probably the more
fun character as well.
- Oh, for sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Charithra] Portia
Featherington, oh my god.
- [Nicola] Portia, she's
the Kris Jenner of regency-
- I loved your family, too,
and all the arc of that whole story.
- [Charithra] Thank you, yeah.
- [Kelly] And then how that unfolded.
I don't wanna spoiler alert if you're lame
and you haven't seen it yet.
You can see seasons one and
two of "Bridgerton" on Netflix.
You'll wanna do that, trust me.
You're welcome.